[Music]
everybody has a tuning fork inside of
them and it goes off when you hit a good
golf shot
whether you're blind or fully sighted
you feel that
[Music]
my name is jeremy poinsnow and i'm the
world blind golf champion
i just turned 19 years old and was on
top of the world and then one day i was
walking on campus and i noticed i had to
squint to redesign two months later i'm
legally blind with no central vision
[Music]
the central blur i have is like a
ghostly fuzzy static image in the middle
that i can't really see anything through
he was a great golfer before and when he
lost his vision he thought he'd never
play again
when my mom told me about blind golf i
thought she was cracking a joke but she
wasn't kidding
i said we can go to the driving range
i'll hit some balls
and if i miss one i'm done
and i didn't miss one
the tuning fork went off but i could
feel that was good i like this
golf
is an individual sport
blind golf is very much a team sport
my name is lionel poinsenneau i'm
originally from france i'm jeremy's
caddy coach guide
and his dad
all blind golfers have a guide someone
who helps them out on every single shot
the first playing golf tournament we
played in it was a lot of bickering back
and forth between my dad and i you would
say well it was your fault now it's your
fault i mean it was it was interesting
i was paired with someone who's totally
blind after the round i shook his hand
and i said john was nice playing with
you and he said jeremy i had a great day
today thank you
and when he said that i was like oh man
he shot a 324 i shot in 97. he's happy
i'm not who's the real winner here
if i said to my dad let's play more like
john cosolo let's be happy and enjoy the
game so that's what we do and it's great
to feel confident going into a round of
golf you want to look good you want to
feel good and then you hope that
translates to playing good
you know he needs to get loose garments
because you can't swing with a very
tight shirt you've got to make sure that
he's comfortable and he's got everything
he needs to play
every player and guy they have a
different process
he kind of describes the hole if it's
tight if it's long and he sets up to the
ball and then from behind he looks at
how my feet are lined up and he tells me
to go a little more right a little more
left i hit the shot and we do that the
whole way around the course good but
[Music]
the first time we went to the world
championship there was no expectations
it'll be fun then jeremy got into a
playoffs
and i thought i got to soak this up so i
smiled and i waved to the crowd
i hit the shot and it came off perfectly
after losing my sight i felt like i was
living a nightmare
in that moment was a total dream and
what's especially cool about it is to be
able to share that experience with my
dad
you